well this is an interesting piece of
news
i'm glad we got the mandatory john cena
thing out of the way yeah
i'm glad we got that out of the way yeah
i can't see him all right guys well
looks like james gunn has announced that
john cena's peacemaker from suicide
squad is getting a straight to series
from hbo max this is an interesting
piece of information i hope that they're
not
jumping the gun
[Music]
i hope they're not getting too ahead of
themselves here i'm excited for this
i'm skeptical about it i have my hopes i
put out a post on the community page
uh for the real rejects asking them what
are their hopes for it
waiting for some more comments to come
in and then uh we'll read through some
of them right now let's break down this
piece of news
so james gunn he tweeted out i'm over
the moon excited to be working on
hashtag peacemaker with my pals john
cena and
the suicide squad producer peter saffron
on this new hbio max original series
john cena said working alongside james
gunn on suicide squad was an absolute
master class in how to best bring
beloved characters to life in a new and
fun way i cannot wait for the dc
universe to experience more of absurdity
as peacemaker in this new project
on hbo max
so james gunn will write all eight
episodes of this show and he's gonna
direct
multiple episodes here peacemaker is uh
a pacifist such an extreme one to the
point that
if you're getting in the middle of peace
he'll go to war with you he's an
interesting fellow this guy i think the
first comics tagline is a
man who loved peace so much he's willing
to fight for it yeah
with john cena playing this character
i'm excited to see what he does with it
now i do have some
anticipation feelings and thoughts for
this show i'm very hopeful that they're
going to make this a hard
r series i imagine they will i've heard
reports that the suicide squad film
will be in fact a pretty hard r with
what you know the dc universe has done
with their television
shows such as doom patrol and harley
quinn two shows that i absolutely love
still haven't seen titans yet
but as far as doom patrol harley quinn
go which are both on hbo max right now
so if you have hbo max if you haven't
seen them
highly recommend them they are both hard
are
weird in all their own ways and knowing
that james gunn is behind this and will
be writing it
and knowing how much character
exploration he loves to do and how great
he can do that within an ensemble piece
with comic book characters i can only
imagine
what he can bring to life here with an
actual television show an eight episode
series my skepticism isn't the
idea that this is straight to series i
feel like a lot of people are excited to
see what he'll do with it and i think
comics fans will be very excited for
peacemaker to have his own series
at the same time though i'm like well we
should
i'm kind of under the impression we
should maybe wait to see
what fan reception is that reception of
the suicide squad at john cena's
you know presence in it before yeah
buying eight episodes and spending all
this money
yeah i have faith in the fact that james
that james gunn is behind it himself
yeah and john cena i think is a really
funny actor
you know whenever he's tried being like
serious badass just don't buy into it
but i think he's
more self-aware of the goofiness that he
naturally
brings even when he's trying to be all
smoldering and serious
yeah he can do the ironic badass very
well yeah badass who thinks he's smarter
than he is or something like that yeah
i imagine this will also have i mean it
would be kind of
odd if it doesn't have like political
messages and undertone surroundings he's
peacemaker for crying out loud
yeah james gunn behind it you got to
imagine that it's going to be
infused yeah i would hope so i mean from
james gunn i usually tend to expect a
certain level of irreverence and a
certain level of
zaniness that's kind of off the beaten
path for the norm but that's the one
thing i guess i would
very much hope for on a show like this
and not that it needs to be watchmen but
i feel like in a fun way it could do its
own
riff on you know a captain america type
thing or yeah just
the irony of the world in general
having so much war and the you know
struggle to maintain peace and having
such a violent character you know in
those pursuits you know there's a lot
you could say with that
and i'm also wondering too what's the
tagline for the suicide squad movie
don't get attached
yeah um a lot of people were actually
under the impression that john cena
would be one of the ones that get offed
in the suicide squad so if anything the
bummer bit of piece of information about
this news
sounds like they're confirming that he's
not one of the characters who will
ultimately get off in the movie but
maybe he could maybe this could be a
prequel series an origin tale
we don't know any of the specifics of
what they're gonna do
i'm hoping that they can get some other
dc characters to really get involved in
here maybe some other members of the
suicide squad
i really like the approach of what dc
generally has been doing with their
adult television shows what they've been
doing with expanding upon their movies
now i mean we got that
gotham show coming out with matt reeves
helping to uh get that off the ground
and then we got james gunn
working on this one that are very
interconnected
to the movies to help expand upon the
lore and flesh out more of the world
from its movie cinematic universes and i
know marvel is doing there's the same
thing
with like shows like wanda vision loki
falcon and winter soldier whatnot
perhaps even more down the road
the fact that they're making this a big
part of their plan
right now hey that must mean that
whatever they've seen
of the suicide squad and what they've
seen of what john cena does
i'm now wondering if he's going to be
the character in the movie who steals
the show whenever he's on screen i could
totally see it he has to at this point
he kind of has to
yeah like that's there's more of a
pressure now for fan reception
on his end because you're announcing the
series you're going to want people to
walk away from that movie
loving whatever the hell it is that
james that james gunn and john cena are
doing you know if you walk away like i
loved everyone else and
johnson was all right yeah it's kind of
a bummer you know yeah yeah but
this could also be an opportunity to
whomever else survives is
assuming this is a continuation and not
a prequel
whoever else survives in the suicide
squad maybe we'll get an opportunity to
make an appearance in here as well
yeah for sure i think it definitely
suggests at least that they must find
something especially special in his
portrayal because that is a stacked cast
and there are a bunch of people who
could easily
go on to their own spin-off show and
it's cool to watch this because it seems
like there is
definitely a big shift happening in
terms of how these tv
shows or you know pseudo tv shows are
made because now they're going even
further down the hole of hiring you know
movie
caliber talent you know not to slag
anybody who makes tv because it's just a
different medium but you know it seems
like marvel and dc more and more aren't
making
what you would assume when you hear like
oh yeah they're making a tv show i
tend to think of the cw when i think of
that right uh and so yeah this seems
like a definite mark
toward yeah both bigger caliber tv and
bigger caliber crossovers between the tv
and the movies right now we got uh
hector g who is the top comment who's
saying there's so many other characters
deserve at hbo max series but it's james
gunn and john cena that will draw in
people
and not the character itself don't care
for it
and that's what i mean how there's a lot
of pressure writing in
on um john cena's portrayal in the
actual movie itself because right now i
can imagine that the only thing that's
really having people interested i'm
talking about general audiences people
who have
no familiarity with peacemaker you know
it's like when you announce the shows
from marvel it's like well we've at
least gotten a chance to be acquainted
with characters like wanda and vision
and falcon and winter soldier we've
gotten a chance to be acquainted with
them
here all we've got are some like
behind-the-scenes snippets so this whole
announcement the enthusiasm for it is
strictly riding on your love or
appreciation
for both john cena and james gunn yeah
but i a lot of my faith in it is also
going to the fact that it's on hbo max
itself it sounds like
whatever dc universe was trying to
become
hbo max is just taking over for it seems
like hbo max is yet to reach the point
where they're like netflix so it's still
special
when they greenlight a show yeah
definitely let's see here nabil
sied said i hope it's full on adult
comedy series
like harley quinn i'm hoping for that
too
uh like doom patrol is a very twisted
and hilarious series but it's also
very heavy and dark at times and uh
harley quinn is 100 a comedy show that
occasionally has
moments of real nuance and emotional
death i imagine that for this one to
work it would be great to get a show a
live-action dc series that is in
continuity with the other dc movies that
is just a complete
comedy and with knowing these two
involved i think it's going to be a
full-on comedy
oh yeah knowing james gunn especially i
mean it's going to be probably
a little gross very funny and probably
ride the edginess line as far as it can
and then colin davis says something
interesting john you want to read it
yeah sure he says at this point after
guardians of the galaxy 3
volume 3 is done dc needs to hand the
reins to the dceu to james gunn
single-handedly can get me excited about
any
character which i mean i can
see i can imagine a lot of people
getting on board with you i mean it's
still
i think it's funny because it does
depend on whether or not the suicide
squad actually pleases everybody as much
as the hype is pleasing everybody but
i could definitely see them handing the
reins to him if
this all goes well i mean it seems like
they definitely have some faith in him i
don't know
exactly what how that clashes or meshes
with their
uh you know continued commitment it
seems like to
you know trusting their creatives with
this stuff and not going quite as
committee but maybe having a guy
like him heading up whatever pseudo
committee they come up with could be a
good thing because he's clearly
intimately
knowledgeable of the comics passionate
about them and he clearly has a
sensibility that appeals to everybody
right now
you know well it's interesting with
james gum because when he got the
suicide squad you know that was when he
was let go of disney and marvel
and then uh so it was more there's a lot
of like
you know speculation is like is this a
big f you to marvel blah blah blah and
then he
in the middle of production or i was out
of pre-production or
actual you know during production then
they
hired him back for guardians of the
galaxy vol 3. if he's going to be
working on this series and then also
working on guards of the galaxy 3
he is the only filmmaker from
both marv from the mcu and the dceu
who will continuously be hopping back
and forth between the two major comic
book franchises
i don't think they would hand it over to
him but i'm excited that it's gonna be
an
ongoing continuing relationship with
james gunn for
both of mcu and dceu that's the part of
it that sounds really intriguing and
also what i'm hoping for
is i know dave bautista expressed
interest in being in the suicide squad
obviously didn't happen
i'm hoping that with dave bautista's
real reverent
love for james gunn that he gets an
opportunity to be in here and i think
fans would be very excited about that if
you could have dave bautista
playing some type of character going toe
to toe
with john cena i think would be very
exciting for a lot of fans yeah
that that's a that's a civil war level
mashup of a whole different variety
that way in the dcu you would have day
bautista john cena
and dwayne johnson as black adam and i
know dwayne johnson and dave bautista
have some weird
riffs going on so i don't know what the
hell is exactly happening there but
they've been having some qualms
um so i think that that would make
things very exciting here's
rich getting this fighting wrestling
world the whole third of the dc here
wrestling but with all them dressed as
different super hero characters or super
villains
all right guys well are you excited for
the show at all leave your thoughts down
below what are your hopes anticipations
for what they do with this series
looking forward to hearing what you got
to cite subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell last but
not least let's do a pic
there's one man at our patreon page who
is a man
who seeks to make peace in the world it
is undoubtedly chris whammo
chris wamoff is a hardcore political
activist
humanist he really cares about each
individual person i know this started
off like i was going to say something
sarcastic
linking it towards the irony that is
peacemaker but if there's someone who
really cares
about the people in the world it is
chris chris i'm happy to know you i hope
things are consistently going well i
know it's been a while since i heard
back from you
but my dude you're with someone who
whenever i talk to brings a lot of
positive light into my heart
i love getting to know you the more and
more i do so please be safe out there
and i hope to hear back from you soon
[Music]
buddy